[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, everyone.
So I actually have a
sixth sense for donuts.
I know where they
are, and I'm sensing
they're right over there.
And all I have to do is
use Android Pay to get one.
Shall we do it?
Yes, we should.
Hey, how are you doing?
SPEAKER 1: Great.
How about yourself?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
doing fantastic.
So what do I do here?
SPEAKER 1: Just tap your phone
with the Android Pay loyalty
card on it and we'll
get you a donut.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There it is.
SPEAKER 1: Which
donut would you like?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The
green one, clearly.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys.
Ah.
That's good.
OK, so Dennis and I
clearly have been using
Android Pay a few more times.
Dennis, tell me about
what just happened there
when I tapped my phone on?
DENNIS: So we're doing,
actually, Tap for Treats.
You get to go to
stations right now.
You, basically, tap through NFC.
And it's a loyalty
card that's set up
that you can collect points
off of every time you do a tap.
So you go to the stations, tap,
we'll give you a nice donut,
some other treats.
After you get four taps, you
can come back to this station
later on in the day and you
can get a free Android Bot.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
this is something
that people are doing all
around the festival today.
DENNIS: Correct.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
I can see, as I've
been passing by
throughout the day,
that it's also
very, very popular.
And I don't think
it's just the donuts.
I think it's all pretty easy.
DENNIS: Yeah, it's
super easy to do.
Literally takes seconds
to actually recognize
through the NFC tap.
People obviously love
Android Bots as well.
So that's probably
another big incentive
of why people are doing it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, and wait.
There's more than
just donuts, right?
DENNIS: There is more
than just donuts.
You actually have a custom
Bot that you can get.
Once you tap four times,
come to this terminal.
People can actually
get a nice free custom
Bot that's specifically
Android Pay and I/O 2017.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
DENNIS: Yeah.
Here you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, really?
Thank you!
DENNIS: All right.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, my hands are full.
I'm going to take care of this
and we'll get something else.
[MUSIC PLAYING]